Pues estaba
ahora hace 10 minutillos así que me lo
he puesto otra vez y estaba probando a
ver si porque sí que he creado una
he creado un archivo y luego lo he
eliminado.
de la
incluso de de la papelera.
Entonces estaba viniendo
aquí a
este lo he probado y ese nada. Este
tampoco.
Vamos a ver este.
Y estamos con una partición de
de Linux E
¿Dónde se? Yo creo que nosotros
dice que usemos un, o sea, hacemos esto
y no lo podemos con lo otro, ¿vale?
A ver, opciones, pero no me da más
opciones. A ver.
Pescado. A ver, ahí dónd estaría.
Tampoco nos va de
lo mismo.
F.
Estamos a lo mismo.
Vale.
Bueno, a ver, he estado, no sé si ayer
lo hablamos, he estado mirando buenas a
todos. Estaba ayer mirando el tema del
el tema del examen, de los exámenes,
¿vale? Los que no tenéis los que no
podéis venir con un portátil, se aquí se
os puede dejar uno. Lo que el único
problema es que tenéis que venir antes
instalar las aplicaciones,
¿vale? Porque sí que es un portátil,
eh,
un portátil sin nada,
tiene el sistema operativo y ya está.
Vale, a lo mejor sí que te encuentras
alguna aplicación residual o algo de
eso. Hombre, yo los miraré antes y eso,
pero vamos, no creo que me imagino que
son un formateo ahí puro y duro y y ya
está. Entonces,
aquí sí que tendréis que venir con
tendréis que venir con tiempo y o sea,
¿por qué? A ver, temas ameneas.
A ver, os digo, ¿eh?
las fechas que no se han movido.
Vale, entonces a ver.
Entonces, por ejemplo,
tendríamos eh
redes el martes 11 a la a las 4.
los que los que necesitáis, o sea, los
que no podéis venir con vuestro
ordenador, tendréis que venir, o sea,
tendréis que avisármelo con días de
antelación también para para tenerlo
todo previsto
y tendréis que venir antes también para
para poder instalar para poder instalar
programas. Ya veremos a ver qué
programas utilizamos.
O sea, en inglés, por ejemplo, lo que os
dije ayer, inglés creo que que va, o
sea, en inglés lo escribís en eh de
a mano, o sea, ahí no hace falta ahí no
hace falta ordenador ninguno
y luego ni IP, pues ni idea tampoco, o
sea, porque eso como lo lleva Pilar, yo
no sé, no sé cómo no sé cómo lo va a
gestionar, me imagino que bueno, no lo
sé porque el otro día Jorge, me suena o
Ramón o Abraham, estuvisteis mirando
tema de currículos, ¿verdad?
Sí, un poco.
Vale, que
sí estuvimos haciendo lo del currículum.
Vale.
Estuvisteis en Canva, ¿no? Con Canva
haciéndolos.
Ajá.
Vale. Pues nada, no lo dejéis eso. Me
imagino os habrá puesto una actividad,
¿no? De
Sí, no, ya lo tengo hecho.
¿Lo tienes hecho? Pues
a ver si me lo quieres ir pasando. A
ver, tampoco no vas a iniciar las
prácticas ya, pero lo digo por ir
teniéndolo ya.
Sí, lo único que me faltaría la foto,
que ella me dijo que no hacía falta para
la tarea, pero pues lo único que me
faltaría sería poner la foto.
Yo soy partidario de no foto, así te lo
digo, porque es una manera de descartar
candidatos muy Ponte en el lugar de
alguien que está
muy visual, ¿no? O sea, a ver, todos le
vamos a poner un mismo un mismo
excesivo. Igual Pilaros ha dicho otra
cosa, no lo sé, pero esto ya es es
criterio mío.
¿Tú le pones un mismo especial a lo que
a lo a lo que la
nos dijo que preferiblemente sí, que no
es necesario, pero que preferiblemente
sí.
Exacto. Preferiblemente sí. Sí, porque
hombre, pues si encuentras una foto que
digas, "Vale, esta es mi foto y estoy a
gusto con esta foto y tal, pero es
complicado también eso." Claro, es como
elegir, no sé, o sea, hay peña que le dé
igual estas cosas
y otros pues que que a lo mejor lo
tenemos un poquito más,
¿no?
No, a mí lo de la foto me da igual. Lo
único que no tengo ninguna foto decente
porque en todas es o en bodas o en
fiestas o
pues eso, una foto decente porque ya
tampoco te da tan igual. Pues lo que
quieres es una foto decente,
o sea, que sea al final una foto, una
captura de un momento, ¿no? Y en esas
fotos que tengas por ahí, pues son en
esos momentos están capturado.
Mm. No, yo que como no me tomo.
Bueno, el caso es ese, o sea, el
currículum con foto y sin foto
lo que queráis poner, la verdad. Pero
bueno, hacer caso a Pilar también con
esto que es la que os lo está la que os
lo está mandando,
¿vale? Y el tema de tener currículum es
más que nada para iniciar vuestro
proceso de de prácticas, ¿vale? Que no
vamos a empezar ya, pero cuanto antes lo
tengamos, vayamos teniendo todo el
material, pues mejor. que imagínate que
a lo mejor nos llama o o nos escribe un
correo una empresa y nos dice, "Oye,
necesito alguien de primero para
prácticas."
Pues tal, ahí está tu currículum, lo
enviamos, ¿sabes? Igual dicen, "Vale,
pues sí, venga, adelante. Te hará una
entrevista posiblemente,
¿vale? Porque a ver, al final son
empresas y no van a meter ahí a, o sea,
querrán verte, querrán saber cómo cómo
funcionas, ¿no? Si ves,
pues eso, lo que veas ser una entrevista
de para conocerte más que nada.
Vale, pues dicho esto, venga, cierro
esto. Así más o menos, o sea, esto creo
que no va a cambiar si, o sea, no, en el
momento que lo tenga claro claro del
todo, os enviaré un correo, ¿vale? Con
las fechas
y así lo tenéis ya. Como estamos todavía
tenemos margen que estamos a 21,
pues nada,
eso que sepáis el tema de los de los
portátiles y las torres y todo eso que
te puedes venir al examen rollo Campus
Party o
o eso o instalar en en un portátil cosa.
Perfecto. Vale,
bueno,
vamos al tema de redes.
¿Qué dirá Álvaro? ¿Estos de qué hablan?
Me están contando a mí un poco, pero
bueno, normal.
Bueno,
vale, voy a ir cerrando cosillas.
Vale, tenemos redes locales hasta las
7:30.
Vale, venga.
Aquí sí que os dije que os iba a enviar,
que os iba a poner algún algún ejercicio
más. Hombre, se han hecho tres, cuatro.
Pues a lo mejor un uno o dos más y que
caen,
¿vale? Y posiblemente pues utilicemos ya
para que tracer
uno. A ver, se ha hecho un dos
3es y cuatro.
nos quedaría uno de tarjetas de red
que ese ese no lo hemos ese no lo hemos
puesto,
¿vale? Y luego haremos simulacro de
examen. El año pasado, bueno, en
presencial lo hacéis también, ¿no? Me
imagino, Álvaro, el simulacros.
Yo el año que estuve no
no
hicimos alguna cosa, pero un simulacro
en sí, ¿no?
Vale, un simulacro no es más que ver que
cómo va a ser el tipo de examen que vais
a hacer y posiblemente salga alguna
pregunta de dentro de ese de ese
simulacro,
¿vale? Lo que estoy viendo que el año
pasado aquí se hizo eh
se el examen
costaba de
A ver.
que lo abra aquí. Vale,
vale. Pues sí, sería sería algo así,
¿vale? Obviamente no va a ser con estos
con estos números, pero sí sí que puedo
sí que podíamos hacer algo así, algo así
como esto.
Vale, este sería la parte práctica.
Esto no es simulacro, esto es examen del
año pasado, ¿vale? es la parte la parte
práctica y
al final pues eso, o sea, se trata un
poquito de
Y luego tenemos uno que es de redes
locales, que sería un cuestionario que
sí que tenéis que hacer desde el
ordenador, o sea, importante.
Yo es que optaría también por por hacer
esto algo híbrido, o sea, no poner
tantas direcciones,
¿vale? Que que sí que vayáis
a lo mejor la mitad y luego un pequeño
ejercicio en Packet Tracer también y
tenemos un poquito de todo.
Creo que creo que va a ser que es algo
mejor, no sé,
¿sabes? Porque es que esto al final
acabas mareado de tanto de tanto buscar
como si fuera una lencana,
¿no? No es el objetivo tampoco.
Vale, pues venga, voy a a ver, vamos a
hacer hoy un ejercicio de con Packet
Tracer.
Ayer estuvimos mirando el tema de de
DHCP. Vamos a ver todo lo que hemos
estado viendo. Vamos a aplicarlo.
Y todo lo que hemos estado viendo no es
más que las tarjetas de
Estuvimos viendo el tema de tarjetas. A
ver que tarjetas de red, por un ejemplo.
Vamos a ver. Espera que abra abra el el
cisco este.
Esto,
¿vale? Ayer estuvimos cogiendo un
server.
Y luego lo hicimos, no sé si si os
acordáis, lo pusimos también con
configuramos con un router también.
mediante comandos
una, o sea, para que asignase
direcciones direcciones IP a los
clientes.
Vale, hoy vamos a
a ver, espera,
vamos a hacer esto mismo que hicimos
ayer.
Vale, cogemos el
el cable de forma automática.
Vale. Y aquí tendríamos solamente
un
net. Vale, vale. La idea es
crear un servidor de NS.
¿Vale? ¿Para qué servía un servidor DNS?
para asignarnos los nombres de, o sea,
para dirigirnos, ¿no?, hacia la como
sería como un traductor de un mano a
máquina.
O sea, nosotros le decimos www, o sea,
wwprueba.com
y el servidor nos envía una IP,
¿vale? Recordando un poquito porque sí
que estuvimos viendo, a ver. H
he.
Tipos de red.
Aquí en
física lo estuvimos viendo por encima,
¿vale? Pero sí que sí que es tema que
aparece, no
no es no es específico de esto porque sé
que lo haremos con más detalle más
adelante,
¿vale?
Pero sí que está está bien que hagamos
todo esto. Vale. Vale. El tema es eh
vamos a crear un servidor DNS que que a
su vez que va a ser este de aquí, va a
asignar direcciones de HCP
a estos a estos a los equipos de la red,
¿vale? Y luego vamos a crear un segundo
servidor
que va a hacer las funciones de servidor
FTP y
servidor web, ¿vale? Y así vemos todo lo
que fue
todo lo que hemos estado viendo en
espera que abra que abra los materiales
de la de la asignatura y os digo
exactamente dónde podemos encontrar
todas estas cosas.
Vale, en IPV4
sí que hombre no en los en el los
apuntes de PV4 no estaría. A ver,
características de las señales, por
supuesto que no
mientras mientras de redan un poco, pero
en el en el tema tres sí que se toca
todo esto por encima.
Vale, sí, sí que se sí que se nota y sí
que viene sí que viene a cuento. O sea,
¿por qué
sí que se toca todo esto y sí que viene
a cuent?
Vale, no os va a salir luego en el
examen una práctica así, pero a lo mejor
de parte de una parte pues a lo mejor sí
que aparece algo.
Vale, pues nada, en primer lugar este
servidor es el que lo vamos a utilizar
como
a ver que esto aquí
est servidor
de
Vale, este sería un servidor de NS que
tendría, por ejemplo, sería 192.168.
Vamos a poner su dirección.
H
punto.
Vamos a hacerlo fácil punto certo
200.
Vale. Y ahora vamos a crear un segundo
servidor,
¿vale? que este es el que nos va nos va
a facilitar el
FTP y los archivos y los archivos de y
los archivos web,
o sea, las páginas web realmente sería
un
servidor http
sería servidor
http
y ftp,
¿vale? Y su IP sería la 192.168.0.21.
Vale, esto no.
Vale, este sería vamos a vamos a nombrar
todo porque sí que queremos sí que
bueno, lo primero que vamos a hacer va a
ser eh asignar
a este a este servidor que asigne las
direcciones IP, ¿vale?
la puerta de enlace. A ver, el
pam.
Vale, espera porque primero tenemos que
configurarlo. Vale, ya estamos aquí.
Vale, venimos aquí.
Su dirección sería 192180.2
Vale
y la máscara de
Bueno, realmente. Vale, vamos a ponernos
así. Venga. Y luego nos venimos aquí a
los servicios.
¿Qué? ¿Qué máscara has puesto?
Te oigo superbajito.
Dime
qué máscara has puesto.
¿Dónde?
En en el server cero. Ahí. Vale. Nada.
Te la pone automático. O sea, en el
momento que le pones que le pones eso,
te añadas la máscara de forma
automática.
Vale.
Vale, un segundo.
Vale, aquí le vamos a poner
la puerta de enlace, que sería por
ejemplo la la uno, o sea, le pondremos,
espera, me lo voy a llevar hacia allá
todo.
Esto lo vamos a poner aquí,
¿vale? Pendíamos este de aquí,
¿vale? Y aquí le pondríamos
192.1680.
168.0.1
servidor de NS la 192.168
punto. O sea, aquí estamos configurando
para que nos para que nos asigne a las
a los demás equipos que estén en que no
estén en estática, que estén con el de,
o sea, diciendo, "Dame dame dirección
IP." Vale, estamos configurándolos para
que configurando la red para que estos
equipos adquieran esa adquieran esa IP,
¿vale? Entonces er0,
perdón, punto 200.
Vale,
aquí podemos poner de la 150,
¿vale? Si le dimos, si le decimos
guardar, nos lo machaca. Vale, bien. Que
es donde estaba yo ayer fallando a la
bestia,
¿vale? Y le decimos que 15 direcciones
oro, pues no queremos más.
Vale. Y activamos el servicio.
¿Vale? Entonces, tenemos por un lado la
puerta de enlace, por otro lado
tendríamos el el tema de las
el tema de la de la DNS, eh,
o sea, el servidor DNS. ¿Qué sería el
servidor DNS? ¿A dónde apunta? Hacia la
hacia la dirección de esta máquina.
Vale. Y activamos el servicio y le
decimos nada que adelante. Entonces,
vale, eh, cerramos esto,
¿vale? Nos venimos aquí
y le decimos que nos asigne una
dirección.
¿Vale? Entonces, como le hemos puesto
que empiece de la 150, este nos lo le
asigna la la 150,
¿vale? A los demás, pues lo mismo. Lo
que sí que vamos a hacer porque este
este archivito os lo os lo subiré,
¿vale? Así lo tenéis en el
lo tenéis en el drive.
A ver, este lo vamos a llamar PC PC1. No
le voy a poner la su dirección IP.
¿Por qué? Pues porque cada vez que
nosotros iniciemos, como está puesto en
automático, o sea, en está puesto para
que para que adquiera una dirección IP,
igual se la asigna primero a este la
siguiente vez que arranquemos el
programa.
¿Vale? Entonces, este lo llamamos PC1.
Hombre, la verdad es que podía haber
cogido esto de aquí y haberlo cambiado,
que era más era más lógico. Pues nada,
PC
01.
Vale, esto me lo cargo.
PC
guarde todo la misma. A ver, PC.
ha puesto este en un
Ah, vale.
Cer
y PC03.
Vale, venga, pues eh activamos
la configuración
IP.
nos venimos a, o sea, porque él ahora,
o sea, lo que lo que realmente tiene, la
dirección que tiene ahora no tiene
porque está dando estática. Si no
hubiera ningún servidor
en marcha y lo tuviéramos en DHCP,
o sea, imagínate que lo tenemos que lo
tuviéramos conectado.
Vamos a hacer una prueba. Vamos a
conectar este. Vamos a conectar un
un PC. Vamos a conectar al a este server
y le vamos a decir,
"Ah, porque no tiene más puertos. Vale,
vale, vale, vale. Pues nada,
claro, lógico.
Pero se se le puede poner un un puerto
más, ¿no?
No, si es que sí, si podemos ponerle más
realmente. Mira, pues mira, eso es una
una buena
Nos venimos aquí, lo apagamos y le
añadimos
esta sería una ta
[Música]
posiblemente este sea el bueno. A ver,
este otro
fastnet, pues esta no ponemos esta y ya
está. Lo ponemos ahí porque ese ese está
vacío. En este momento ya tendríamos
dos. Lo iniciamos.
¿Vale? Entonces
aquí ya tenemos dos, una encendida que
se estaría conectada al Lois, está
encendida.
Bueno, lo vemos también aquí. Aquí
tenemos cer y uno. O sea, si hacemos la
A ver, por si por si no lo habéis
entendido alguien la operación porque a
lo mejor se ha hecho muy rápida.
Vale, aquí sería. Apagamos,
quitamos,
cerramos.
Volvemos a las configuraciones y vemos,
bueno, ahora está apagado, ¿vale? Lo
entendemos y vemos que solo tiene una
tarjeta de red, ¿vale? El tema de
tarjetas de red es lo que hemos estado
mirando también en este durante esta
durante esta evaluación,
¿vale? es realmente lo que comunica al
al sistema con con la con el resto de la
red
en cada dispositivo. Una tarjeta de red
puede ser un una
puede ser un wifi perfectamente.
En este caso, pues va a ser una conexión
de cable,
¿eh? Vale, vamos por aquí. Vale, acá
habíamos cogido esta, si no recuerdo
mal, ¿qué diferencia hay entre esta? Ah,
esta es Gavid, esta es
fase eterno,
del del óptico es bu. Vamos a [__]
esta.
Luego esto sería
un wifi y luego esto sería un mod 4G.
3G.
Vale, ponemos esta
que es la misma que esta de aquí.
Entiendo. Sí. Vale. E iniciamos.
Vale, lo que yo quería hacer era
este. Lo lo tenemos en estática,
o sea, para en estática significa eso,
le ponemos nosotros la dirección IP, se
la configuramos nosotros,
¿vale? Y aquí ella nos conecta
mediante hable cruzado porque entiende
que son dos dos,
o sea, son dos máquinas
en la que están, bueno, serían iguales,
aunque uno es cliente y otro servidor,
pero no tiene el estatus ese a la hora
de, o sea, la tarjeta de red que tú has
puesto aquí puede estar perfectamente
aquí. De hecho, aquí también nos dejará
añadirle,
si tiene huequecillos, nos dejará
añadirle cualquier otra tarjeta. A ver,
alguna que sea doble igual. A ver.
No,
a ver, aquí
no. que son todas simples. E esto y este
módulo no, esto nada.
Vale, era por ponerle otra diferente.
Vale, entonces tenemos
que este server no está no está lanzando
nada realmente.
No lo hemos configurado de ninguna
manera,
¿vale? está con su dirección estática,
pero todavía no lo tenemos configurado.
Y ahora nos venimos aquí y le decimos
que nos asigne una dirección IP,
¿vale? Y nos coge una pipa. ¿Por qué?
Pues porque no nos está tirando, no nos
está lanzando
todavía hasta hasta que nosotros le le
digamos aquí que
bueno, lo veremos ahora.
Vale, de todas maneras este nos lo vamos
a nos lo vamos a cargar.
Vale,
vale. Aquí tenemos este, aquí tenemos
este otro.
Realmente es un dispositivo que está
dentro de la red, pero no está
configurado correctamente.
Y este sí que nos va a [__] otra vez la
otra vez, ¿no? O sea, nos va a [__] la
lo que es la dirección
que envía el que asigna este servidor,
¿vale? que luego aquí podemos entrar en,
o sea, se pueden realmente es que claro,
este está bastante limitado, ¿no? Por
luego en las opciones de un
de desde HCP son bastante amplias, o
sea, no se limita a decir, "Vale, de
aquí hasta aquí." O sea, se pueden se
puede añadir explosiones, eh
restricciones,
[Música]
Vale,
vale. Estábamos con la Vale, vamos ahora
vamos a a crear
vamos a crear el el
tema de del servidor de NS, ¿vale? Lo
que vamos lo que le vamos a decir ahora
es que cuando nosotros escribamos en
cualquiera de estos clientes,
escribamos la dirección que queremos, o
sea, la dirección que pongamos, nos nos
redirija a la página web que tenemos
alojada en este servidor,
¿vale? Y esto lo esto lo conseguimos
mediante la implementación del de las
DNS,
¿vale? Que estas las tendríamos aquí,
¿vale? Y aquí lo único que le tenemos
que decir es, ¿vale? cuando cuando desde
este cliente que ya está en la red
eh hm te esté pidiendo, o sea, te esté
escribiendo
esta dirección, por ejemplo, le podemos
poner web,
esperar en minúscula
web
punto
mm
podemos poner prueba
punto
comom, por ejemplo.
Vale. ¿Y cuál y cuál sería la dirección
de seprueba.com. Vamos a alojarlo aquí
en este de aquí en el servidor HTTP.
¿Cuál sería la dirección? La dirección
IP
192 1681.
Sí, exacto. Esa sería 19 damos punto 1.
¿Por qué? Pues porque nos porque
nosotros le estamos diciendo, "A ver, yo
tengo este nombre que se llama
prueba.com,
eh,
y el servidor nos dice, "Vale, pues
prueba.com es esta dirección y te envío
hacia él.
punto0 punto 2011,
¿vale? Y lo añadimos,
lo activamos
y lo añadimos. Esto sería prueba.com.
Vale,
vamos por partes. Primero vamos a hacer
el vamos a hacer el DNS. Exacto.
Vale, este ya lo tendríamos. Vale, ahora
nos iríamos al al servidor
al servidor eh web o Sí, exacto. Vale,
nos venimos aquí.
Vale. Y ahora a este sí que le tenemos
que decir
que eh, o sea, tenemos que poner su
dirección porque antes no se la habíamos
puesto,
¿vale? Que sería 192.16
[Música]
8 pun 0.21 2011
y la máscara la esta.
Vale, ahora aquí lo que tenemos que
bueno, ¿no? Eso, o sea, simplemente aquí
nos vendríamos
nos vendríamos a HTTP, ¿vale? que sería
el servicio, porque aquí sí que tenemos
en este servidor tenemos el HTTP activo,
o sea, sin un http, sin un servidor
activo, dentro de ese servidor no habría
manera, por más que nosotros tuviéramos
los archivos eh dentro de la máquina,
pero sin si no tenemos ningún servidor,
no podríamos hacer absolutamente nada.
Creo que esto lo estuvimos mirando así
por encima, ¿verdad? Es que me suena que
que con vosotros sí que estuvimos con
vosotros de primero sí que estuvimos
mirando con el
con mediante Sam, por ejemplo, os suena
que lo estuvimos mirando o con o
mediante
mediante la herramienta de Windows, que
es IS.
Os no sé si os acordáis que estuvimos
mirando una página, una página muy
sencillita, un código HTML.
Bueno, cualquier caso, eso, o sea, hace
falta hace falta que que haya un
servidor en marcha, que sería
básicamente esto. O sea, lo tenemos
encendido. Si nosotros apagamos ese
servidor
no tendríamos nada que hacer. Vale, esta
sería la página, el index, que es la
página que que va a aparecer,
¿vale? Cuando nosotros desde un cliente
de estos pidamos pidamos la la esta.
Vale, lo que vamos a hacer, por ejemplo,
esto te lo muestra de alguna manera el
index este,
a ver, vamos a ver.
copy.
Eh,
es que no quiero.
Vale, esto lo que nos mostraría. Vamos a
vamos a un editor.
Esto no lo abre.
Es por no abrir el Visual Studio,
¿sabes?
Pera más que nada. Vale, pues da igual.
Mira, entramos desde aquí a la página
index.
Vamos a entrar desde el desp.
Como aquí ya tenemos asignada una
dirección IP. A ver,
vale. A ver, espera.
Nos venimos
eh lo lo puedes guardar en un bloque de
notas y lo guardas como HTML.
Sí, sí, era por no por no liarla. O sea,
realmente esto ahora estoy desde el
servidor, ¿vale? Es era para que la
viéramos,
pero era por no hacer más historias y no
sacar más archivos y guardar y todo el
rollo.
¿Vale? Entonces, eh aquí poniendo la
propia dirección del del buen aquí
realmente sería un local host, pero
también podemos podemos poner la
dirección propia del Ah, así Cisco local
host,
¿vale?
que sería eh
uno un es que no sé cómo lo va a tratar
esto. Yo creo que sí que lo estuvimos
viendo con vosotros el tema de Vale,
sería esto, ¿vale? Cisco packet packet
tercer esto sería lo que estábamos
viendo en el
aquí,
¿vale? Este sería este código. Si
nosotros ahora le decimos, "Ponme estas
letras así de y estas y en vez de en
azul las ponemos rojas
o verdes o
ponemos rojas. Red, por ejemplo, no sé
si admitirá. Espera,
puesto comillas, tío.
Vale,
vale. Y aquí a lo mejor pues podemos
poner una, no sé, una imagen o bueno,
vamos a dejarlo así,
¿vale? Entonces, nos venimos aquí otra
vez, le decimos que vale. Y ahora pues
eso, o sea, realmente sí que nos está
leyendo el código ese dentro de la
máquina.
Vale, pero lo que nosotros queremos
hacer ahora es que verlo desde un desde
un cliente,
¿vale? Porque si nosotros ahora nos
venimos aquí,
esto lo voy a cerrar.
Ahora nos venimos aquí y le decimos,
¿vale? Le decimos, le pone, apuntamos,
por ejemplo, a la dirección del
servidor, que sería 192.168.0.
Hombre, realmente sí que lo va a
implementar
porque tenemos el servidor activo, pero
a ver, esperad, eh, que vamos a
voy a cambiar,
voy a desactivar. Realmente lo estamos
mirando con http,
no con la versión
segura.
Vale, si está apagado no va. Vale, va,
nos da igual. Lo hacemos así y ya está.
Vale, está encendido. Vale, entonces nos
vamos aquí.
Venga, ahí como ya tengo implementado, a
ver lo qué es lo que hemos hecho. Hemos
creado aquí un
un DNS, ¿vale?
Este DNS nos apunta a este servidor.
Este servidor eh
entrega la página que está pidiendo el
cliente. Vale, sería Sí, sería
básicamente eso. No sé si Cisco me va a
permitir el el poner la dirección IP y
que me aparezca directamente el
navegador. Sí, exacto. Esto es lo mismo.
Vale, ahora nos está leyendo de este
servidor.
Vale, de hecho, si nosotros, a ver, esto
lo pongo aquí,
¿vale? Sí, eso lo dejo ahí. Me vengo
aquí.
Jolín, vale, me vengo aquí. Es que es un
jaleo de ventajas.
Me vengo aquí y le digo,
"Edítame
esto y en vez de de cinco, ponlas de
ponlas de uno. Y ahora en color,
espera,
ponemos de uno, o sea, van a ser super
chiquitillas y en vez de rojo, pues yo
que sé, ponemos black.
y guardamos.
Y en vezco
Packet tracer, lo que ponemos es prueba
super original.
Pues entonces vamos a hacerlo ahí más
grande por lo menos que luzca. Ponemos
un seis. Veamos
seis. Vale, le decimos guardar. Que sí,
que lo guarde. Cerramos. Nos venimos
aquí, le decimos, "Vale, adelante." Y
ahora vemos que que efectivamente sí que
está cogiendo
de de esta dirección. ¿Por qué? Porque
es esta dirección y nosotros la sabemos.
Ahora, imaginar que nosotros esta
dirección realmente no la sabemos. O
sea, que que ese
esta dirección IP nosotros no la
sabemos. Nosotros solamente sabemos,
como somos humanos, realmente lo que
sabemos es
webw.prueba.com.
[Música]
¿Vale? Y le damos a intro y nos aparece.
¿Por qué? Pues porque el servidor DNS
nos está traduciendo
de de humano a máquina o de máquina a
humano el
bueno, en este caso de de humano a
máquina nos está traduciendo esta
dirección, ¿vale? Y es más que nada este
ejercicio es para que veáis cómo cómo
funciona un servidor
un un servidor DNS.
Vale, el siguiente paso
sería implementar también un tipo de
servidor
eh FTP.
Vale, estuvimos viendo el tema de FTP,
también lo hemos estado viendo por
encima, creo que a ver,
dejar que mide los
apuntes. A ver.
Esto, Jorge, tú que estuviste el otro
día con lo que me decías de
de montándote la movida esa de servidor
de juegos y todo eso.
Hm. Sí,
tiene tiene cosas que ver, ¿no?, con un
poquito.
A ver, lo mío fue mucho más sencillo.
Fue un puerto y la
portátil y
que va, pero eso no es sencillo, hombre.
Eso es. No, no está no están no lo veo
sencillo. Vamos.
Lo que pasa que cuando sabemos hacer
algo, disculpar, eh, una
seguro no lo veías tan sencillo antes de
ponerte a hacerlo. Luego cuando ya
dices, "Astra", vale, pues no era para
tanto, pero claro,
hasta que llegas a ese proceso de de que
lo has hecho y no te ha salido bien,
pues
vale. Venga. Eh,
a ver,
vale, vamos a ver el tema de FTP. Bueno,
sin antes sí que vamos a probarlo desde
desde estos de aquí porque vamos a
estado probando desde aquí.
Vale, ¿qué pasaría ahora si Bueno, sí,
vamos a probarlo desde aquí,
¿vale? Entonces nos nos venimos aquí al
al navegador,
hacemos wew web we punto
eh
prueba
comom.
Vale, ahí tendríamos a mí, a mí eso no
me funciona.
No te qué
me funciona la IP y ya la página no.
¿Qué IP te funciona?
Eh, estoy poniendo la que termina en 200
y sí que me enseña la página, pero al
poner la página web así no me sale
porque no has implementado el el
servidor de NS. Mira que lo tengas así.
Tú le tienes que decir realmente
a la máquina el nombre de, o sea, que
que cuando alguien te pida prueba.com
wwprueba.com,
tú lo envías aquí.
Vale.
Sí, pero he puesto exactamente eso y no
me deja.
Igual lo tienes apagado,
¿no? Entendido. Pues pues pon
comparte pantalla si quieres.
A ver, espera que lo lo llevo para allá.
¡Uf! Es que a ver.
A ver, ¿en qué te has asignado bien las
las direcciones IP a los clientes?
Vale, si lo tienes bien,
vete a DNS. Vale, a ver cómo lo tienes.
Prueba 168021.
Está encendido.
Eso lo tienes bien. Vale, aquí.
Vete a No, aquí realmente vale, mira lo
que te pasa.
Lo tienes apagado el HTTP.
Parda un poco, ¿eh? el el naveadorcillo
ese.
Ahora sí era eso. Es lo que estábamos
hablando. Sí, igual ha seguido, perdón,
igual han seguido los pasos cuando
estábamos ahí hablando. No, si estás
hablando este Jorge no, no apareces
hablando. Ah, vale, ahora
vale, vale.
Que yo pensaba que solo teniendo este se
podía.
Este es, acuérdate lo que te dije, http,
pero con la con el cifrado de de
seguridad. Vale,
pues nada,
vale, realmente, a ver, haz una prueba,
mira, quítale, o sea, vete al server
y desactiva HTTP, o sea, le dices off y
el otro ahora pones, te vienes aquí y le
dices https
a ver si a ver Cisco cómo funciona con
esto también porque igual
[Música]
Vale. Eh, https
ps
ahora
dos puntos barra era.
Sí, dos puntos barra barra. Espera,
creo que sí. Vamos, sea la vida
viéndolo.
Es barra barra para el otro lado.
Sí, sí que se puede.
Sí, así. Si, pero si si ahora le quitas
la S te dirá que que ni de coña.
Sí,
sí.
No, porque está porque está pagado
realmente. A ver.
Bueno, no ves,
ahora no.
Ahora no. Había que darle un tiempo a la
cachet
con ese sí porque lo tienes activado.
Vale, pues eso, o sea, realmente
funciona exactamente igual.
Si, pues eso, o sea, si claro, tú
imagínate que tienes el servidor de
páginas web de tu de tu servidor donde
estás emitiendo,
donde estás donde tienes alojada esa
página que la tienes en local y
imagínate que tienes ese server apagado.
O sea, es no es más que esto, por
ejemplo, espera, mira, os voy a poner
esta es tu pantalla compartida o es o es
la mía. Ya no, ya no la tuya.
Madre mía, es que de verdad el el zoom
este.
Bueno,
por ejemplo, aquí
no sé si con vosotros hemos estado hemos
estado viendo esto, o sea, esto es un
servidor de
de apache, bueno, es un servidor de de
páginas web. para Windows, ¿vale? Que no
funciona, no funciona mal. Entonces,
claro, ¿qué pasa si yo me vengo?
Vale, voy a hacer la voy a hacer la
prueba. Yo ahora me vengo al navegador.
Vale, cierro esto, cierro esto, cierro
esto, cierro esto y cierro esto.
Vale, si yo ahora le digo
local host
a 11 que es que digamos que es donde
donde me apunta,
no me no me entrega nada, ¿vale? porque
lo tengo apagado. Pero si yo ahora le
digo,
"Enciéndete,
enciende la patch y enciende el MySQL.
Realmente MySQL creo que no haría falta
para esta página web, pero bueno.
Vale, si yo le digo local host 11 creo
que no. A ver, no me deja. Vale, sí,
ahora
local host realmente
eh, o sea, lo que lo que os quería decir
que A1 realmente es
Vale, sí, sí, se en este caso sí, no es
que tenía confusión con el con el
servicio este de Microsoft también,
¿vale? Esto sería un servidor de, o sea,
lo digo por si queréis curiosear,
investigar, no es algo que vayamos a
tocar ahora para corto plazo, ¿vale?
Pero
pero no está además que todo este tipo
de cosas las vayáis vayáis sabiendo y
vayáis sabiendo dónde están. O sea,
igual que en algún momento pues también
cogeremos e instalaremos
instalaremos el
un servidor en Linux
de de páginas web, ¿vale? Y podemos
instalar WordPress también y ese tipo de
cosas.
H,
o sea, sin salirnos de lo que es el
temario, pero
pero eso para que vayamos viendo que
todos esta este tipo de cosas se pueden
ir haciendo, ¿vale? Esto sería la página
que está que está emitiendo o que está
alojada en este servidor web que está
dentro de mi ordenador.
¿Vale? yo,
o sea, si yo le digo,
me vengo,
voy a editar el el archivito
que está
a ver que me acuerde
está aquí a 11
sería el index,
por ejemplo. Por ejemplo,
abrir con lo de notas.
No, este no es,
es esto. Vale, entonces lo que vamos a
editar es, por ejemplo, este título de
arriba,
¿vale? Lo digo por no buscar algo así
más
hasta la cabecera el body. A ver. Tranca
trc.
Eh, perdona,
aquí está. Dime.
Es que me tendría que ir ahora.
Ah, vale, Álvaro, nada, no pasa nada, no
te preocupes. Se queda grabado, pues
eso, o sea, si quieres verlo luego, pues
sí, lo veré.
Venga,
vale. Gracias. Adiós.
Ti hasta luego.
Vale, aquí tenemos el título este,
¿vale? Que sería guía simple para crear
HTML. Pues aquí decimos,
nos lo cargamos. Esto estaría en el
estaría en la en el GAT. A ver. Y luego
en la
A ver, espera un segundo, eh. Vale,
estructura básica. Vale, no nos venimos
a este de aquí.
Aprende lo básico. A ver, guía. Vale, es
este de aquí. Vale, eso este no sería,
sería este de aquí. Guía. simple para
crear HTML. Le decimos
aquí ponemos pues nada, vamos a tirar
ahí de originalidad y le ponemos prueba
mayúscula.
Prueba, ¿vale?
El estilo realmente no nos, o sea, aquí
ahora, o sea, si yo le digo,
le digo control G,
lo guardaría y ahora aquí en el
navegador le digo F5
y aparece, aparece. Pero si yo ahora, a
ver, lo digo por meternos así un poquito
en ya en HTML y [__] un poquito de
Pero vamos, pinceladillas. Entonces nos
vendríamos aquí. Vamos al a ver que
ahora me ahora me he perdido. ¿Dónde
está? Vale, aquí en A 11 nos vamos al a
los estilos,
¿vale? Al archivo de estilos. ¿Sabéis
que un h un HTML puede llevar los
los estilos dentro de la propia página,
dentro del propio código o los puede
llevar en un en un archivito.
¿Veis? Aquí tenemos un un trozo de
código en el que nos está diciendo que
los estilos los estilos no es más que
qué tipo de letra voy a utilizar aquí,
qué color, qué tamaño, qué tal, ¿vale?
tanto en los tanto en títulos como en, o
sea, no realmente podemos podemos dar
formato,
igual que en Word dábamos formato de una
manera, pues aquí los estilos serían la
manera de dar formato. El código sería
como nosotros,
el código HTM HTML sería como nosotros
vamos poniendo la información, o sea,
bienen listas, bien en párrafos, bien
como título, bien como bien como una
imagen, bien como un vídeo, ¿vale? Y
luego los estilos es lo que nos ayuda a
darle a que aquello parezca bonito, que
no parezca que no parezca una página de
los años 90 a principios,
¿vale? Entonces, estilos
nos vendríamos aquí,
lo denotas, lo abrimos y ahora le vamos
a decir que
a ver
porque hemos fijaos la etiqueta que
tiene, ¿vale? Esto que nos está diciendo
que es el tipo. Bueno, realmente
si queréis os paso el paso el archivito
y podéis hacer vosotros la prueba
por el chat.
Este igual sí que os lo pasé yo. Es que
sí que me suena este
que sí que sí que estuvimos mirando esto
así por encima.
Mira, os paso index y asilos
por el chat. A ver si me coge los dos.
Sí,
vale. Esos los lo tenéis que poner en
una carpeta, ¿vale? Para poder abrirlos
en la que estén siempre en la misma
carpeta, porque cuando en el código se
viene,
cuando en el código le dices
esta ruta entiende que es la raíz. Si si
aquí hubiéramos puesto una subcarpeta, o
sea, por ejemplo, eh
estilo, una carpeta se llame estilos,
¿vale? Entonces aquí tendríamos que
poner estilos
estilos barra,
bueno, lo he puesto en mayúscula, pero
se entiende, ¿no? Que podríamos haberlo
puesto en minúscula.
Estilos barra, o sea, siempre te busca
siempre la raíz la entiende, la raíz de
de esa estructura de directorios. la
entiende desde su propia, si no le
indicamos nada, lo entiende que es desde
su propia
desde su propia carpeta, donde está el
archivo index,
que es el que te va a leer, o sea, el
que te va a leer el protocolo http por
defecto cuando tú cuando tú abres una
cuando tú abres una página,
perdonar.
Vale, me he perdido un poco con todo
esto, pero es que bueno, a ver,
estábamos con el tema de los estilos,
¿vale? Y vamos a cambiar el
los H1,
¿vale? Entonces,
los H1 están configurados,
pues no los veo. A ver,
estas de las del body.
Vale, aquí le podemos decir que las que
las letras de es que estoy buscando.
Vale, aquí está.
margin boton. Vale, le podemos decir que
el color de Ah, pero esto es el a ver,
le podemos decir que sea negro. A ver si
lo va.
A ver, vamos a ver.
Le podemos decir esto. Es que hay cosas
que te que te coge por defecto. Vale,
vamos a decirle que el text
mm
es que no sé si va a [__] esto
exactamente.
Vale,
entonces y aquí le vamos a decir
una No, no estoy seguro, eh, no se lo
vaya a hacer. Bueno, le decimos que
no
a ver qué nos hace
guardar.
Nos venimos aquí.
[Música]
Nadie no ha tocado
absolutamente nada porque no estábamos
no estaba hablando de eso. Vale, vamos a
[__] otra cosa evidentes de cargo.
Esto no va a ser
ostas.
Vale, le vamos a decir que los H2, que
me imagino que serán
un color
ponder [__]
Cambiarlo porque ¿qué diferencia? Vale,
aquí vemos que los H2, que serían estos
los títulos que él llama H2, este sería
el título H1. Solo puede haber un H1 en
cada página.
Estos serían los H2 y estos los H3 que
tiene un color diferente. Entonces, lo
que nosotros vamos a hacer es que los H3
y los H2 tengan el mismo color. Por ¿por
qué? Pues porque nos gusta más.
Entonces, cogemos el color de aquí de
de DH H3
y nos lo llevamos aquí.
Vale, ahora tendríamos el mismo. Le
decimos guardar y si esto realmente es
porque yo creo que sí que es H2, no es
que no lo miro en el código, ¿vale? Como
estoy con lo de los estilos. Vale, le
damos
actualizar.
A ver,
vale, un H. ¿Dónde
estamos?
Vale,
H2, paso uno, estructuras básicas.
Paso uno, estructura básica. Sí, sí, sí.
Vale. Es que nos lo debería haber nos lo
debería haber cambiado.
Vale. A ver,
eh, control G.
Estamos dentro de
ver.
Vamos a cambiar este también.
Era 333.
Puesto 888. A ver,
estoy cogiendo el archivo este.
A ver si es que escrito aquí.
No, no, está bien.
Vale, pues no sé, no sé que puede estar
pasando, pero vamos, o sea, sí que
debería de haber hecho cambios,
pero bueno, no era no era el lo que
queríamos lo que queríamos ver tampoco.
Vale, pues lo dejo como estaba.
era eh 333
porque no está comentado ni nada.
Estilos muy simples.
Si le pongo
el body verdana según lo cambia.
Segundo guardar.
que pasa de México. Bueno, vale,
vale, vale, vale, vale, vale, vale.
Si es esto.
Bueno, pues nada, es por lo menos el
el index este sí que lo ha cambiado. El
paso uno, estructura básica,
prueba y m
Bueno, esto sí que lo está tocando.
Actualizar.
Bueno, vale.
Me hubiera gustado que que cambiasen lo
el tema de los estilos, pero
tampoco era lo que estábamos viendo
porque estábamos estábamos con el tema
de, o sea, íbamos a implementar el tema
de FTP.
que básicamente
vamos a hacerlo así rapidillo, ¿vale? Y
y por lo menos que se vea.
Vale, bueno, esto lo cierro.
cierro el servidor que, o sea, lo que
hemos emulado realmente en el
en el packet tracer sería el sería el
server.
Vale, entonces lo que vamos a hacer
ahora es implementar el el FTP.
El FTP,
¿vale? Aquí tendríamos
aquí lo que Vale, ¿cómo funciona FTP? O
sea, nosotros tenemos activo el
servicio, ¿vale? Lo tenemos desactivado.
En este caso tenemos espera que cierre
el programa este.
Vale, cerrado.
Incrado.
Vale.
Eh,
así por encima, pinceladas, ¿vale?
Nosotros lo que lo que creamos son
usuarios. Con esos usuarios podemos
desde los diferentes equipos clientes lo
podemos hacer anónimo,
¿no? Es aquí no creo que aquí creo que
no deja
no creo que no está la opción podríamos
hacer un usuario anónimo de FTP. FTP no
es más que lo que veíamos en los en los
apuntes, un servicio de ficheros de de
compartición de ficheros.
centralizado, ¿vale? No es lo mismo que
un torrent que son compartición de
ficheros descentralizado completamente
el que tú eres servidor y agradeceres
cliente.
Aquí uno actúa como como server, como un
servidor, que sería el caso de del
servidor http y FTP, o sea, http porque
hemos implementado los dos servicios,
pero si solo hubiéramos puesto FTP, pues
este sería un servidor de FTP, ¿vale? Y
luego está el cliente, pero está
centralizado aquí. Los archivos están
aquí y los descargamos de aquí y lo
subimos de aquí, o sea, lo subimos de
aquí a aquí.
Vale, entonces
el servidor FTP.
A ver,
vale, vamos a crear un un usuario,
un usuario nuevo,
eh, que se llame pues prueba,
prueba
y su password va a ser prueba también.
Muy bien.
Vale, prueba y prueba ahí el usuario,
¿vale? Y le vamos a dar permisos de
de escritura, lectura, borrado,
renombrado y listado,
¿vale?
Y le decimos que adelante,
que que lo añado, ¿vale? Y ahora vamos a
crear
un prueba dos
prueba dos con permisos de lectura
y listado
simplemente.
Vale. Y también pruebados, ¿vale? eh su
password. Vale, pues venga, lo añadimos
y tendríamos esto. Y lo que vamos a
hacer ahora es que desde
Vale, vamos a ir cerrando cosas que si
no
abiertos, ¿no?
Vale, ahora desde la consola
lo que vamos a es a apuntar a este a
este servidor FTP,
¿vale? Porque ahora ya no le vamos a
decir al DNS, dime dónde está el FTP
tal,
que se lo podríamos se lo podríamos
decir también, pero es que creo que
Cisco no lo no lo no lo hace bien esto.
Vale, entonces nosotros lo que
tendríamos que poner ahora es FTP.
Estamos, recordar que estamos desde el
PC1, eh, estamos desde aquí, que es el
que está
el que está en el que está así en en
como desvanecido, ¿vale? Entonces, le
diríamos FTP, la dirección de de nuestro
servidor FTP, que sería el 192
168.0.21.
¿Vale? Entonces, le damos intro y nos
dice,
eh, o sea, porque a ver, bueno, si
queréis lo hacemos desde aquí y le vamos
a decir,
nos vamos a ir al servidor DNS y le y
vamos a intentar hacer ese FTP también,
que sería 192.168.0.200,
[Música]
¿vale? y nos envía, espera, del vale,
del del PC2 al poner la dirección del
DNS también nos está Vale, pues lo hace
bien, lo hace bien el el Cisco este.
Vale, tenemos que podemos acceder desde
aquí, ¿vale? nos deja acceder desde aquí
porque nos está enviando al al a la
dirección de CTP a no ser de qué.
Vale, no narices
lo tenía activado.
Ahora no nos dejará.
Vale,
vale, le decimos FTP
192.168 168 pun
pun 200 y no os va a decir que nada
que no encuentra, ¿vale? No es que lo
realmente sí que lo podríamos haber eh
con un server sí que sí que podíamos
haber direccionado hacia
hacia
perdón hacia el FTP, hacia nuestro
servidor FTP,
pero nosotros eso realmente no lo hemos
implementado todavía.
¿Vale? Nosotros lo que hacemos es
directamente entramos al FTP,
control C. Ahora lo vamos a hacer desde
lo tenemos abierto desde aquí, desde
este, ¿vale? Que aquí nos está pidiendo
usuario, usuario, contraseña, o sea,
primero usuario, luego nos pedía
contraseña y ahora estamos en este
también que vamos a decirle
192.168.0.201,
¿vale? que sí que sería la dirección del
FTP. Ay, perdón. Y aquí pongo
FTP porque si no no entiende que le
estamos diciendo.
Vale, FTB.
Vale, nos venimos aquí, le decimos que
que intro, ¿vale? Y tenemos la misma
tenemos lo mismo que nos está pidiendo
aquí, ¿vale? O sea, realmente nos está
pidiendo el usuario. Aquí, ¿qué le vamos
a poner? Aquí le vamos a poner el prueba
dos,
que recordar que tenía permisos de
eh lectura y listado, simplemente
no le va a dejar que escriba nada. Vale,
ahora nos pide el nos pide la password,
¿vale? Que sería prueba dos para hacerlo
sencillito.
Intro,
¿vale? Y aquí ya funcionaríamos,
o sea, realmente los servidores FTP sí
que funcionan funcionan así, ¿vale? los
que son modo consola, si entramos en
filecila y
todo esto, pues pues sí que lo vamos a
hacer en modo gráfico, ¿vale? Le
diríamos de dir y nos lista todos los
archivos, ¿vale? Ahora, por ejemplo,
nosotros le decimos,
eh,
podemos leer estos archivos,
pero no podemos escribirlos,
¿vale? Entonces,
si yo ahora, por ejemplo, le digo
rename,
o sea, que me renombre
o o voy a intentar crear un directorio,
¿vale? dentro de este más que renombrar
decirle mecadir
eh
prueba
posiblemente
invalido, ¿no? Que no soporta el comando
este. Vale.
Mm, pues a mí me suena de usarlo, ¿eh? A
ver, Ren,
no es que a ver, os lo digo porque no
vale dir sí que me deja y rename Rene.
No me va a dejar tampoco y me va a poner
lo mismo.
Rename. Eh, la este primero, por
ejemplo, Asa 842.
842-k
punto binombrar
todo el archivo, no me va a dejar,
¿eh? Y luego lo probamos en el otro que
tiene que tiene todos los permisos,
¿vale? Eh, lo vamos a renombrar por un a
a
puntxt. ¿Por qué no?
Vale. Y me dice que
qué permiso en negado. Vale, es que eso
es lo que yo h cuando le he dicho el
McKadir lo que esperaba que me pusiera.
Permiso enegado.
Vale, pero ahora, sin embargo, nos
venimos aquí al
al PC1, le decimos que
nos está pidiendo el user name y le
ponemos prueba.
Este ya no es prueba dos. Este tiene
todos los permisos.
Prueba
otra vez. Prueba intro. Vale, decimos de
dir, le decimos
mk.
le puesto antes.
Vale, quiero crear un directorio se
llame
prueba
y posiblemente me ponga No es que no es
que ese comando no lo tiene.
No sé, no sé cuál será realmente
para crear un directorio,
para crear una carpeta en físico. ¿Cómo
era?
Vale, pero sí que vamos a renombrar este
primero, ¿vale? Porque como tenemos
todos los permisos,
eh, que pone ASA, no, ASA, ASA 842.
ASA 842. Realmente lo podíamos haber
hecho más sencillo
en el server
K8
pun bin por un A. A a a A a sí. a y otra
a punto txt.
Vale. Y ahora a ver si le he puesto a 0
K8.bin. Subid.
Vale,
entonces no os lo Okay. Eh, vale, que se
ha hecho bien. Vale, ahora le decimos
unir y la primera el primer
el primer fichero de la lista
es efectivamente el que hemos el que
hemos creado, ¿vale? Y así podríamos con
con comandos de de FTP como son app, eh
podríamos subir.
Es que en Cisco no sé no sé exactamente
cómo funcionan,
cuáles son los comandos exactos, ¿vale?
Pero sí que podríamos subir archivos
desde desde el cliente, desde la máquina
al cliente hasta
el servidor. Luego los podría leer este
porque tiene permisos de lectura, el PC2
y no sé, o sea, FTP, la verdad es que
está en una red local es genial. Luego a
nivel
a nivel de una red abierta ya es ya hay
que implementar muchísima seguridad,
¿vale? que para eso ya estaría el
el SFTP. Hay hay dos protocolos, dos
servicios más de FTP, ¿vale? Para
para implementar todo esto. Bueno, pues
lo dejamos dejamos servicios,
o sea, redes locales hasta aquí.
A ver.
Vale, voy a apagar